we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we did reach
seven hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers yesterday and today's
voicemail is about that hey david rayman
here congratulations on getting to seven
hundred thousand subscribers thank you
curious if the goal is 1 million what
are you gonna do to entice more
subscribers you're gonna do the more
shows with no product in your hair
you're going to do
[Music]
jiangha games fun yeah listen I mean my
thought is I don't know that we should
be drastically changing what we're doing
in order to get to a million subscribers
that's an amazing goal based on the
recent subscriber trends we are sort of
on target to hit a million YouTube
subscribers in June of 2020 and in great
time for the 2020 election it would be
amazing to be covering the 2020 election
as a YouTube channel with over a million
subscribers but to be honest the the
growth curve has been accelerating it
only took us four months to get four
months to get our last hundred thousand
subscribers it took seven months to get
the prior hundred thousand so it's
accelerating and I don't know that I'm
inclined to change much of anything
we're gonna just keep doing our thing
and part of that is doing not only a
really good broadcast show every day but
a really good bonus show every day on
today's we will talk about Donald
Trump's latest unhinged Afghanistan
comments as well as two men who have
been bizarrely fined for eating raw
squirrels to protest a veganism a very
very strange way to protest all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show